heirloom is interesting concept and only
in the country of India have they
bothered to delineate the real
definitions by law in American parlance
here in the North American continent we
generally assume the term heirloom to
mean any plant or possibly animal that
was in production and broadly popular
prior to fifty years ago in 2010 that
means 1960 that would include parts of
the Green Revolution in hybrids now so
there's some controversy surrounding the
word heirloom good bad indifferent is
probably above my pay grade we prefer to
use the word land race to delineate the
fact that older seeds plants animals are
developed on a farm over ages not just
lately with the intervention of modern
science
well we generally use the word around
the globe Green Revolution but the
advent of industrialization coincided
around the world at different times but
certainly between say the late 1700s and
the late 1800s in that century you saw
tremendous industrial development
everywhere and it seems to be matched
hand-in-hand with scientific advances
and it's not to qualify whether they're
good or bad but the scientific advances
of seedsman ship in my field where
you're dealing with grains where a
scientist actually is improving and I
put that in quotes on what had
heretofore been only landrace plants
I think and I think that I can repeat
what geneticists that are associated
with breeding and addressing famine and
addressing plant disease worldwide in
their later years seemed to drift into
where I believe the answer to your
question lives and and it's a tough
question so the immediate answer is I
think landrace plants are vital and
critical to our future does that make
them better I'm not so sure the quality
assessments important certainly my work
with them I like the foods associated
with landrace plants and animals at this
point in history better than I like what
we've been doing with the Green
Revolution and modern scientific
breeding that's a personal opinion on a
scientific and worldwide judgment I
think that you have to take application
into the answer if you're talking about
small farming for a local community and
small-scale distribution which means
radiuses of less than say 20 miles
there's no question that land race
plants are far superior period and
animals to a better flavor better
nutrition all this not documented in
America but some work in EU certainly in
the UNESCO field certainly in a aja
there's been a lot of work on this but
when you speak about commodities and
having to feed the world and address
famine and global climate change if you
lump all those things in then the
definition of the vigorous and vital
nature of land raised plants becomes
pretty arcane immediately because those
plants the Landry's plants are the
building blocks for modern foods period
you can't improve quote unquote modern
foods without the genetics of the
original language landrace plants which
were in the public domain
through history until relatively
recently now that's more privatized it's
more the domain of large corporations
who are engaged in these massive
economies so when you ask are they
better it brings this cascade of large
concepts into such a humble thing as a
human improved plant system so my answer
is on a small scale there's no question
Landry's plants are superior on a large
scale i think the verdicts out
in the short term landrace systems in
general both plants and animals so when
you say landrace animals as make sure we
have that clear that heritage breeds is
what we're current term we used in
America when you think of that entire
system of land race plants and animals
it's far more expensive to start doing
it since in our sphere in North America
most of the land race farming has been
gone for at least a century and some of
it's been gone for almost two centuries
and in my fields practically it's
definitely been gone for more than a
century there are pockets of places like
in the weed industry where some land
race plants survive in the commodities
production system Kansas is a good
example where turkey wheat survives
Canada is even a better example where
red Fife wheat which is both of these
weeds Turkey and red Fife wheats are
both land race wheats they're in high
production not low production and
they're part of the commodities industry
they're still more expensive and in
general I think to begin farming
landry's plants the way they're supposed
to be farmed which means low fertility
low hydration requirements they don't
require a lot of water in fact some of
them don't want it a high tolerance for
pests and disease stress really high
tolerance for climatic stress that's how
they survived over millennia to become
foods that we have in modern times when
you look at those to begin using them is
relatively inexpensive which is why our
NGO systems look at land race plants
when they're thinking about third world
agriculture because it takes nothing to
get it grown conversely to apply those
same land race systems to virgin ground
where there hasn't been a culture for
landrace systems is very expensive you
can't go to a seed company and by
reasonably priced see you can't find it
anywhere you can get a hundred grams
greenbank somewhere if you're lucky and
you understand science because all those
sources use numbers and Latin so you
have to be familiar on a scientific
basis with how botany and taxonomy and
morphology works and that's very
difficult for a layperson to jump that
little hurdle and then the next problem
would be what exactly are the methods
that maintain crops in a land raid
system over the long term so once I say
they're very expensive in the short term
because you have to be your own seed
company your own farmer and then your
own processor because a lot of these
things aren't suitable to modern
processing neither are they suitable to
modern distribution once you cover those
problems or challenges and you actually
get past them the expense of the system
starts moving down and in the long term
having native fertility which means
you're bringing nothing on to a farm
having or your own seed production which
means you're not having to buy seed and
having your processing distribution
being right in your immediate area cuts
all these costs and they become far less
expensive in the long term but in the
modern age I'd say since 1970 when
interest in this really began there are
some good examples but they're pretty
sparse so far it's coming and it's
coming at exponential speeds the
developments really gratifying to see as
I sit here I couldn't have probably even
discussed this two years ago with any
credibility and it's great to see it
happening